tenemos aquí la estructura de puntos de
la molécula et y no a la que también le
llamamos acetileno y pues podemos ver
que son dos carbonos enlazados con un
triple enlace y dos hidrógenos podemos
ver también que cada uno de estos
carbonos está enlazado únicamente con
otros dos átomos que este carbono está
enlazado con este otro carbono y con
este hidrógeno y lo mismo sucede con
este carbono entonces esos dos hechos
que tengamos aquí un enlace triple y que
cada carbono está enlazado únicamente
con dos átomos me hace pensar que la
hibridación de los orbitales de este
carbono no es ninguna que hayamos visto
todavía este carbono no va a tener una
hibridación de tipo sp3 o sp2
para ver qué tipo de hibridación tienen
estos carbonos pues vamos a ver la
notación orbital
tenemos aquí otra vez a un estado
excitado donde uno de los electrones del
orbital 12 ya fue promovido a un orbital
2 p que antes estaba vacío y como
podemos ver en el acetileno cada uno de
los carbonos hace únicamente dos enlaces
por lo cual únicamente vamos a tener dos
órbitas híbridas así es que pues vamos a
subir el nivel de energía de este
orbital y va a quedar como por aquí
y únicamente vamos a tomar un orbital de
tipo 2 p para bajarle la energía a este
nivel
y entonces nos quedan intactos dos
orbitales de tipo p
y entonces estos dos orbitales seguir y
dicen tenemos aquí un orbital de tipo s
y un orbital de tipo p y al híbri lizar
se nos quedan dos orbitales de tipo sp
s&p porque tenemos únicamente un orbital
de tipo p y un orbital de tipo s y
entonces a esto se le llama hibridación
y me da
acción excepto y entonces este carbono
es un carbono abril izado sp al igual
que este otro carbono porque los dos
están haciendo únicamente dos enlaces y
los otros dos enlaces que podrían hacer
los otros dos electrones de valencia
están formando aquí este triple enlace y
bueno estos orbitales híbridos este p
ahora tiene el 50% del carácter de la
naturaleza de un orbital de tipo s y 50%
del carácter de un orbital de tipo p
porque se están mezclando un orbital de
tipo s y un orbital de tipo p y entonces
pues podemos esperar que estos nuevos
orbitales híbridos esp sean más
parecidos a los orbitales s y como los
orbitales s son es más esféricos y más
apegados al núcleo entonces pues estos
orbitales híbridos esp van a ser más
chicos pero de todas formas tienen un
lóbulo frontal y otro lóbulo por atrás
que vamos a ignorar a la hora de
dibujarlo para que esté más claro el
dibujo claro que estos lóbulos van a ser
más chicos y van a estar más pegados al
núcleo bueno pero regresamos a la
molécula tenemos aquí en nuestra
molécula de acetileno y sabemos que cada
uno de estos carbonos está y brid izado
sp o sea que tiene dos orbitales de tipo
p y dos orbitales híbridos esp y lo que
vamos a hacer ahora es dibujar esta
molécula pero con todos sus orbitales y
vamos a empezar por dibujar estos
orbitales híbridos
entonces en el acetileno tenemos dos
carbono
empezamos con uno de ellos que tiene dos
orbitales híbridos esp y está uno de los
orbitales híbridos s&p recuerda que no
estamos dibujando el lóbulo de atrás y
aquí está el otro orbital híbrido esp y
cada uno de estos orbitales tiene un
electrón de valencia girando en este
lóbulo y el lóbulo de atrás que no
estamos dibujando luego tenemos el otro
carbono por acá con sus dos orbitales
híbridos esp y cada orbital híbrido con
sus electrones de valencia y tenemos que
cada uno de estos carbonos está enlazado
con un hidrógeno y el hidrógeno tiene un
solo electrón de valencia en un orbital
de tipo s y los orbitales s son
esféricos así es que los dibujamos así
con su electrón de valencia y por aquí
tenemos que este carbono está enlazado
con otro hidrógeno este su órbita
con su electrón de valencia si
regresamos al diagrama de orbitales aquí
podemos ver que cada uno de los carbonos
esp y british a 2 tiene otros dos
orbitales que no hemos dibujado que son
dos orbitales de tipo p ok y además
estos dos orbitales no están libre
visados entonces pues nos falta dibujar
los estos orbitales de tipo p son como
unas mancuernas aunque entonces tenemos
aquí
un solo orbital de tipo p aunque todo
esto de aquí es un solo orbital de tipo
p que tiene un electrón de valencia todo
esto es uno solo de estos orbitales de
tipo p entonces nos falta dibujar otro
orbital de tipo p
y aquí está el otro orbital de tipo p
con su electrón de valencia y bueno
tenemos que hacer lo mismo para este
otro carbono que tiene otros dos
orbitales de tipo p que no hemos
dibujado así es que por aquí está un
orbital de tipo p con su electrón de
valencia y aquí está el otro orbital de
tipo p con su electrón de valencia
entonces ya que dibujamos esto pues
vamos a analizarlo no a ver aquí tenemos
que estos dos orbitales híbridos esp se
están interceptando en un lugar que está
en medio de los dos núcleos de estos
átomos entonces esto es un enlace sigma
lo mismo estamos observando por acá lo
que tenemos que esta intersección está
entre los núcleos de estos dos átomos
entonces esta intersección de este
orbital híbrido esp del carbono y este
orbital 1s del hidrógeno también es un
enlace sigma y
no este es exactamente el mismo caso
entonces en este diagrama podemos ver
que la molécula de acetileno tiene tres
enlaces sigma ahora si nos fijamos en
los orbitales p pues estos orbitales
definitivamente no se van a interceptar
en ningún punto que esté en medio de los
núcleos sin embargo si nos fijamos bien
en las moléculas estos núcleos seguro
estarían muchísimo más cerca y lo que
estaríamos observando es una
intersección lateral de estos orbitales
y entonces podríamos observar
que entre estos dos orbitales hay un
enlace pi y bueno lo mismo ocurriría con
estos otros dos orbitales de tipo p no
se van a interceptar en ningún punto que
esté entre estos dos núcleos pero sí se
van a interceptar lateralmente formando
un enlace pi
así es que la molécula de acetileno
tiene tres enlaces sigma y dos enlaces
pi
ahora que más nos puede decir todo esto
bueno pues si nos fijamos en el enlace
entre estos dos carbonos sabemos que
este es un enlace triple tenemos aquí un
enlace sigma y dos enlaces pi y además
este enlace sigma se conforma de
orbitales híbridos esp y los orbitales
híbridos esp son más cortos que los
orbitales híbridos sp2 o sp3 porque son
la hibridación de un orbitales y un
orbital pero entonces tienen mucho del
carácter de los orbitales s los cuales
están muy apegados al núcleo
entonces los enlaces triples son más
cortos
pero bueno volvamos a escribir la
estructura de puntos del acetileno
tenemos aquí dos carbonos que están
enlazados en un triple enlace y cada uno
enlazado con un hidrógeno y sin tener
que dibujar todo este diagrama podemos
ver cuántos enlaces sigma y cuántos
enlaces pitt tiene lo que hacemos es
contar los enlaces simples 1 2 y sabemos
que en el enlace triple uno de los
enlaces es un enlace sigma en realidad
no importa cuál de estos tres es el
enlace sigma entonces voy a decir que es
este así es que tenemos tres enlaces
sigma y si quiero saber cuántos enlaces
pi
hay sabemos que cuando hay un enlace
triple uno de esos enlaces es un enlace
sigma pero los otros dos son enlaces pi
entonces tenemos dos enlaces pi y lo
repito una vez más este enlace de aquí
entre estos dos carbonos es más corto
que los enlaces simples o los enlaces
dobles porque para formar un triple
enlace tienes que hacer una hibridación
s
donde nada más estás combinando una
orbitales y un orbital p y entonces esos
orbitales son más cortos y por lo tanto
el enlace también pero bueno ahora vamos
a calcular este ángulo de enlace que
bueno es igual a este ángulo de enlace
también ok es el ángulo entre estos dos
enlaces el enlace del hidrógeno con el
carbono y el enlace del carbono con el
otro carbono no podemos regresar un
segundo a este dibujo y podemos ver que
los núcleos de todos estos átomos están
en una línea recta y eso lo que implica
es que el ángulo entre estos tres puntos
este ángulo es de 180 grados y si te
fijas los ángulos de enlace los
determinan las órbitas híbridas por otro
lado los orbitales p estabilizan a esta
molécula y además impiden que haya
rotación sobre este enlace pero bueno me
parece un muy buen momento para hacer un
ejemplo que incluya la hibridación s
psp2
ep3
entonces tenemos por aquí entonces
tenemos aquí una molécula un poco más
complicada y una muy buena pregunta que
nos podríamos hacer es cuál es el estado
de hibridación de cada uno de estos
carbonos entonces por ejemplo si nos
fijamos en este carbono pues este
carbono tiene un doble enlace y dos
enlaces simples por lo que tiene tres
enlaces sigma y un enlace pi así es que
a la hora de utilizar sus orbitales tomo
un orbital de tipo s y dos orbitales de
tipo p dejando un orbital de tipo p
libre para hacer este doble enlace y
entonces tiene tres orbitales híbridos
sp2 y bueno podemos decir exactamente lo
mismo de este otro carbono
este carbono de aquí tiene cuatro
enlaces sigma entonces mezclo todos los
orbitales del segundo nivel de energía
así es que es un carbono jibril izado
sp3 y bueno estos dos carbonos pues
acabamos de ver en este vídeo que son
carbonos híbridos esp y bueno también
podemos pensar en la estructura de esta
molécula vamos a empezar con el carbono
abril izado sp3 como vimos en el vídeo
de orbitales híbridos sp3 cuando el
carbón tiene orbitales híbridos sp3
estos átomos formen un tetraedro ok y
estos enlaces podemos pensar que están
en forma de triple y entonces el ángulo
entre cada uno de estos enlaces es de
109 punto 5 por otro lado si nos fijamos
en estos dos carbonos pues podemos
recordar el vídeo de orbitales híbridos
sp2 y entonces sabemos que estas cuatro
moléculas se encuentran en un plano
y el ángulo de enlace entre cualesquiera
de estos enlaces es de 120 grados ahora
si nos vemos con esta otra parte de la
molécula pues ya vimos que estos dos
carbono son carbonos híbridos esp y
acabamos de ver en este vídeo que eso
hace que formen una línea recta y
entonces los ángulos entre estos enlaces
son de 180 grados
por eso los dibujen en una línea recta
en este diagrama y ahora pues vamos a
contar cuántos enlaces son de tipo sigma
y cuántos son de tipo pi
entonces pues empezamos a contar todos
los enlaces simples son enlaces sigma
entonces tenemos 12
4 y por otro lado vimos en el vídeo de
orbitales híbridos sp2 que cuando
tenemos un enlace doble uno de esos
enlaces es de tipo sigma y el otro de
tipo pi
pero bueno le estamos contando los
enlaces tipos sigma entonces llevamos 5
6 7 8 9 y vimos en este vídeo que cuando
tenemos un enlace triple también uno de
esos enlaces es de tipo sigma entonces
tenemos 10 enlaces de tipo sigma y
entonces ahora vamos a contar cuántos
enlaces pin hay en un enlace doble hay
un enlace de tipo pi y en un enlace
triple hay dos enlaces de tipo pi
entonces tenemos tres enlaces de tipo
pin